وتحقق الحلم بالنسبه للارجنتين يحتفلون
بكاس العالم للمره الثالثه بعد ما قام
قائد ومنتخب هنا الظاهره بالنسبه لهم ليو
ميسي برفع الكاس الذي انتظروه لمده 36
عاما هم يحتفلون او وسط العاصمه بولس ايرس
كان في مختلف المدن والولايات الارجنتينيه
في هذا الفوز الكبير الذي انتظروه منذ عهد
الظاهره على الارجنتينيه التاريخيه دييغو
مارادونا عام
1986هم يعيشون هذه الاجواء اليوم بعد
فوزهم بكاس العالم قطر عام 2020 احتفالات
كبيره فرحه عامره تغمر
الارجنتينيين في كل مكان كما لدى مشجعينهم
في مختلفه انحاء العالم همم نسمعه ايضا
اراء الارجنتينيين هنا في هذه
[موسيقى]
هم يعبرون عن ساعدتهم يقولون الا شيئا يصف
فرحتهم بهذا اليوم من العاصمه الارجنتينيه
بولو سايرس حسام مسعود الجزيره